moi franchement est ce que vous auriez
préféré que tout ça n'arrive pas gens
qui en bavent oui alors non je veux dire
je rêve je parle pas de la publicité
keat mais la chose elle-même
oui parce que j'ai peur en ayant des
donc comme ça qu'il a une vie pas très
heureuse parce qu on a des dents on doit
donner on doit les faire valoir
et nous incluons découvre les
possibilités du conte doit faire plus on
est obligé
de le faire cette écriture au tableau
noir qui n'est plus celle d'un écolier
qui n'est pas encore celle qu'on peut
attendre d'un étudiant résolvant des
équations de mathématiques c'est celle
de gens freinent le conscrit de l'onj
dont la presse a vanté les exploits on
sait qu'il a quitté l'école il ya six
ans après le certificat d'études mais
que les tests psychotechniques que
l'armée lui a fait subir pour son
incorporation à lyon ont révélé un
niveau d'intelligence exceptionnel au
point que le colonel responsable du
centre lui obtenu un sursis tout à fait
inhabituelle grâce auquel il peut suivre
les cours de physique de chimie et de
mathématiques que lui donnent
bénévolement de jeunes officiers en
quatre mois il a déjà rattrapé plus de
quatre années de mathématiques
son talent son génie disent certains
c'est d'abord cela résoudrait les
problèmes plus vite que les autres si
vite qu'il a étonné même le médecin
psychiatre chez qui on l'a menée après
ses premiers succès pour lui faire subir
de nouveaux tests
pour vous donner un exemple le jour où
j'ai passé
rennes par exemple et la flèche
cette épreuve là en seconde c'est à dire
qu'il a assemblé ses pièces pratiquement
sans avoir jamais vu cette figure il les
a rassemblés à la vitesse où vient le
fait n'est ce pas il a compris
immédiatement de quoi il s'agissait vos
autres clients m comines dans général la
tolérance est de deux minutes et demie à
trois minutes
bon pour essayer d'y voir clair il
fallait revenir en arrière remontez dans
la vie de jean allonge de son village
natal nous avons rencontré certes et
reste la maîtresse d'école c'était ça ça
classissima siècle a suivi d'exercices
je crois d'ailleurs voilà à la place
nous y ait pris je suis un v6 à la place
de jean la place qu'il occupait
autrefois quand tu lèves la classe
jusqu'à quel âge jusqu'à 14 ans je suis
un certificat d'études
est ce que c'était de bon élève c'était
un très bon anglais oui
le seul point que je l'an prochain c'est
que tu achètes reçu caillet et qui ne
l'est pas bien comme il faut votre mail
est très intelligent grammaire puis
mathématiques et tout et tout dupuis
alors ils étaient huit quelquefois
premier pour toujours mais enfin
quelques fois oui et puis qu'est ce que
je dis on sentait qu'il faisait son
travail d'intelligence sans trop se
bousculent et
qu'ensuite il que
ces séparant les
lemmy à l'école livre justement pas
l'école communale les frênes ont
toujours été élevé dans une école équipe
c'est une tradition et la tradition de
famille oui le payer très religieux très
religieux
est ce que vous pensez connaît une sorte
de ne pas faire poursuivre ses études
agents de la difficulté j'ai bien
réfléchi
mais à ce moment là la famille est
d'être pauvre il ne se puis non données
demandées pas question non plus il
fallait qu'ils l'aident à la campagne
vous avez parlé j'en ai pas parlé non
parce que on voyait bien qu'il ne
pouvait pas réparé il fallait qu'il
parte en pension il ne pouvait pas payer
à ce moment là
interrogés les uns et les autres c'était
notre idée avant d'arriver mais 40
journalistes en une semaine cela avait
sans doute effrayé tout le monde longe
c'est à quelques dizaines de kilomètres
de lyon est très loin dans le temps les
volets étaient fermés n'y avait personne
dans les rues enfin valeur de midi nous
avons tout de même rencontré quelques
personnes qui rentraient du travail est
d'abord au bistrot épicerie la fille de
la maison
vous le connaissiez
quand il n'était il avait quelques
caractères
il était tout le temps on voyait qu'il
était plus intelligent il était d'à
lecture toujours dans les lectures pour
lui c'était jusque les hommes sa seule
distraction tout et comment vous saviez
lisais dans la rue vous voyez quand ils
allaient dehors avec nous il était
toutefois la lecture est toujours un qui
vous avez travaillé avec lui vous croyez
pour battage au crédit bail
comment ils étaient
violentes et ça nous donne mon
commandement à tout mais je trouve m ou
mois du lundi une bande de foie il ya
pas digéré la manière dans paris on
n'entend pas mon cheptel
qu'est ce qu'ils disaient quand on lui
dit
telle boutique
vous pensiez pas qui lui arriverait tout
ça or banon pourra poster pas commercial
je veux dire il n'avait pas l'air plus
exigeant que les autres
il avait vite compris pour dire de
il avait vite appris à manier la la
mention de la pâte et
vous pensez qu'il sera plus heureux
comme ça que s'il était resté allongé
ici
mais ce qui s'il était bien toute la
tranquillité et faire leurs études bien
été obligé de travailler quand même
aussi non alors j'ai travaillé
auparavant
chez les frais non s'était carrément
barricadé il a fallu attendre devant la
porte le retour du père de gens qui
travaillent en usine à rive de gier
quand il est arrivé la nuit tombée
alors monsieur fred où il a des gens
maintenant à bell aliant
qu'est ce qui va lui arriver je sais pas
ce qu'il a fait
sap a une idée quand même ben non pas du
tout
c'est quand les impôts sur des études
voilà d'où
on sait que c'est bien tout ce qui lui
arrive non
je sais pas vous franchement qu'est ce
que vous auriez préféré
sylla capable
ne riez pas préféré qu'ils restent là
avec vous non bah oui mais ça ne m'a été
obligé de faire son service était bien
obligé de pâtes et je vous dis vous
n'auriez pas préféré avoir un garçon
comme les autres quoi ah oui plus
naturel oui vous pensez pas qu'il aurait
été mieux à la maison rue il m'aurait
bien mieux aider c'est ça va me freine
elle était dans sa cuisine qu'est-ce que
c'était un bon élève
comme les autres moyens et les mamans
qui se faisait punir mais finir par sa
tête est pas parce que
comme tous les gosses quoi il était de
plus ou moins bon élève que ses frères
et soeurs
au contraire dans les miens et bien il
me semblait qu'il y en avait deux ou
trois qui que j'aurais cru qui aurait au
mieux des moyens que lui qui m'en fais à
l'effet que je m'en suis aperçu que
vous auriez mais continuez vous
passez a toujours été j'ai une soirée de
lecture toute ma vie de d'étudier toute
ma vie mais avec onze enfants et puis la
guerre et les privations depuis la mise
s est pas question d culié vous avez pu
lire un petit peu a envoyé tout ce qui
me tombe
toujours du bon pied
sa vie
vivre aussi avec attention car ce que
m'a procuré oui est ce que vous lisez
l'histoire des grandes aventures des
choses au gré des biographies plus des
romans le roman pour de lancer nous
parce que je pensais
et quand vous faites pour vous procurer
ce livre qu'attend peu d'entrées tu
perds ma fille qui m'a la peur d'eux
dans un an ça vous arrive
on pense souvent
vous m'avez dit tout à l'heure que vous
auriez aimé être être nomade ah oui pour
découvrir enfin j'aime toujours des 15
très riche ce match était une petite
roulotte puissent partir et
oui c'est la même envie de connaître la
curiosité
et c'est vous qui avez donné ce goût de
la lecture gens
pour moi qui devais donner seulement il
a vécu toutes avaient cours mais ils me
voyaient lire par le dimanche parce que
la semaine avec toute cette bande
premier le temps de m'amuser mais enfin
le dimanche après midi on entend sortir
et si j'ai trop loin pour voyager à pied
de port jocelyne mas dimanche univers
où le soir nom propre soit
monsieur fred qu'est ce qu'ils disaient
que j'allais aux enfants
le feu à tous ses livres ce n'est pas
pareil maintenant pour qu'elles y voit
qu'ils sont arrivés au temps les uns que
les autres à monter un petit peu
il faut moi j'ai l'impression que
tous vos enfants les gens en particulier
nous doivent beaucoup parce que ils ont
vu des livres la maison ils ont vu ils
vous ont vu intéressé par
avance au cinquième jeu préféré les voir
rire que d'aller voir aller courir comme
il y en a tant
la même un champ il y en avait convient
que j'en entends tu es l'hélios il est
bien sûr que je surveillais ballon le
plus en fait on est d'accord qu'il dise
enfin mais n'avait pas tellement
tu tombes qui avait beaucoup trop de
lait dans la maison
dite moi franchement est ce que vous
auriez préféré que tout ça n'arrive pas
gens ont bien joué alors non je veux
dire je rêve je parle pas de la
publicité qui est un mais la chose
elle-même
le voyez parce que j'ai peur en ayant tu
es donc comme ça qu'il a une vie pas
très heureuse parce que en a des dents
on doit donner
on doit les faire valoir
et nous en plus on découvre les
possibilités de ce qu'on doit faire plus
on est obligé
de le faire
alors un somme il a vécu 21 bien
tranquille ici mais je crois que
maintenant son bonheur est fini de l'opt
il serait heureux si fait ce qui lui
plaît oui parce que la conscience
aux consoles de tout avec une bonne
conscience on est toujours heureux dans
n'importe quelle position c'est ce que
je demande pour lui qui reste
consciencieux simple est-ce que vous
avez le sentiment d'être différent des
autres l'envi n'ai jamais eu d'ailleurs
maintenant quoi et je ne pense pas que
ce soit tellement différent des autres
encore
je ne pense pas
est-ce que ce que vous sentiez plus doué
que les autres
non
pas spécialement
je savais que j'étais pas bête
évidemment mes
potes plus doué que les autres non
est ce que dans vos dents les choses que
vous faisiez dans le travail à la ferme
dans je pense enfin ce que vous aviez le
sentiment que vous
même au point de vue outils enfin au
point de vue le comprenez plus vite ce
qu'il fallait faire quand il fallait le
faire je ne sais pas oui peut-être pour
certaines choses quoi
quelque chose mal
pour comprendre dans la mécanique pour
conduire un tracteur pour conduire un
tracteur
ceux ci
j'ai pas mis longtemps à prendre quoi et
c'est difficile de comprendre penser que
c'est difficile de combler un break ça
dépend pour quoi faire si on va tout
droit c'est pas difficile mais si fort
qu'il est avec leurs morts sur des
manoeuvres c'est assez compliqué mais
qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que c'est pour vous
l'intelligence est ce que c'est de
résoudre les problèmes mathématiques
rapidement
je sais pas c'est assez relatif
l'intelligence relatifs à quoi
et au niveau d'intelligence des hôtes
des personnes quand vos toi
quoi c'est c'est une comparaison si on
peut dire
est-ce que depuis et puis quand vous a
dit que vous étiez intelligent ce que
vous sentez plus intelligente avant
pense pas sas a rien changé pour va rien
changer non
facile vous avez peut-être l'occasion de
de l'exercer davantage nous en
travaillant avec vos professeurs
oui évidemment mais
avait ce qu'il faut être plus
intelligent moins intelligent pour faire
les travaux des chambres devant un
tableau noir oui je crois qu'il faut de
l'intelligence il faut de partout même
pour travailler la terre
la même c'est pas forcément la même mais
il faut toujours
qu'est ce que vous lisez comme livre
actuellement
au service c'est pourquoi je lui avais
lu si vous avez vu qu'ils étaient en
train de lire tintin mais appartient de
synchroniser un peu tout
quoi on déclasse et surtout actuellement
puisqu'elle est figé tulle je suis les
cours de français il faut quand même pu
me documente à l'école normale
quelques classiques
combien on a lu molière
mais pour l'instant on est en train de
faire
corneille
pas de bol
ça dépend
ça vous fait pas tellement corneille ou
molière je suis d'intéressant
une hausse fait un certain nombre
ce qui vous est arrivé est ce qu'on
pensait que c'est
que c'est juste que c'est injuste
comment cela
que c'est injuste pour vis-à-vis
d'autres par exemple fait est-ce que
vous pensez que vous êtes privilégiées
oui j'ai privilégié
et je sais qu'il sut priviligié quoi
vous pensez que c'est que vous le
méritez ou bien que c'est une chose qui
vous est arrivé comme ça
je mérite peut-être un peu mais je suis
sûr qu'il y en a d'autres qui le
mériteraient aussi
et qu'on ne connaît pas et qu'on ne
connaît pas remis
dans dix ans l'avenir aujourd'hui
inconnue de gens freinent sarah feu à
loches il y aura un nouveau conscrits ce
petit garçon là qui rentrent de la
classe
souhaitons-lui seulement s'il a le
talent bien on freine de ne pas être
obligés d'attendre l'instant de son
service militaire pour passer ces
baccalauréat
[Musique]